Hey everybody,
welcome back and coffee on a Tuesday and
blog.
Fifty three.
Okay.
Here's the story,
and the theory in the 15th century,
a dynastic civil war known today as the
war of the roses resulted in the
annihilation of virtually every member
of the British aristocracy.
In the end,
it was henry tutor,
distant cousin of the Lancaster family,
who in 1485 ascended to become king
henry the seventh.
Now,
to keep order,
Henry has to build himself and
aristocracy.
The only problem is all the royals are
dead.
So what does he do?
He pulls people up from the petty
nobility,
the lower classes,
and by introducing social mobility to
Western society,
he initiates what is arguably the most
important movement in all of human
history.
Maternity.
It might be hard to imagine since it's
so much a part of our lives today,
but before this,
social stratification was rigidly fixed.
You were born into a class and you
stayed there for life,
and as the hierarchy was determined by
God,
people literally thought it was
impossible to change their status.
The providential plan was the
providential plans that old henry know
what he was doing.
No,
he was acting out of necessity,
but all of a sudden what the public
thought was impossible was happening
right in front of their eyes.
A massive change in culture for many a
positive one,
and because it was so positive,
people began to reorganize the rules of
their symbolic reality to accommodate.
I talked more about symbolic reality in
blog 46 time.
Essentially it's the symbols in logic by
which we live our lives.
For the first time in history,
the word nation became synonymous with
the word people.
People began to govern themselves,
make their own laws,
and God steadily lost influence in both
political and human affairs,
but in the midst of all these positive
changes,
something very dark and very troubling
was stirring beneath the surface.
The world's very first mental
institution place called Bedlam in
London,
began to take on more and more.
Patients cries,
so hideous and so great.
Show the inner walls.
According to one resident,
what was happening?
Well,
the widespread psychological diseases we
know today as manic depression and
schizophrenia were being diagnosed for
the very first time in feudal England
society where your lot in life was
ordained by God personal crises.
What undermines these illnesses were
uncommon.
You can't really fail at what you are
because your identity in a system like
that was secured at birth in the new
system,
the system of social mobility and
ambitious.
Another word that enters common usage at
that time,
choice becomes a part of the equation.
The responsibility falls off God's
shoulders and onto your.
Suddenly you can fail at becoming what
you want to become with no one to blame,
but you.
This was the bittersweet upshot of the
new modern well.
Many were reaping the positive rewards
of climbing the social ladder.
Others were plunging into personal
crises by failing to do so.
No longer secured by the class of your
birth.
Personal identity needed something to
balance out.
The dark side of modernity.
Enter will shakespeare.
When new worlds are birthed from boulder
failings,
new logics fill the vacuum from pieces
made of the old.
It takes an imagination of a truly great
stature to see and think through,
in essence,
create the principles by which the rest
of us can live our lives in the new
world,
that kind of person,
the rarest of rare we call genius around
1593.
At the height of this cultural upheaval,
Shakespeare writes Romeo and Juliet.
In this play,
we have basically the rule book.
The best definition of what we know
today as low no texts before this
elevates love is such an incredible
height.
No texts is it the same quality and
value in language,
the most important of symbolic system.
Shakespeare's mine was an
extraordinarily close coordination with
the world around him.
He could see what was happening to the
people of London,
the city like most cities played host to
a number of the mentally disabled,
most of whom had nowhere to go and so
remain homeless.
Shakespeare sees it all and we get
amazing diagnostic insights into these
conditions in place like King Lear and
handled in Romeo and Juliet.
He offers a solution.
Love the poet,
writes and signup.
One 16 is the star to every wandering
bark.
In other words,
the north star to every wandering mind.
Shakespeare effectively establishes,
loves transformative power of power for
the average citizen that it did not have
before.
This kind of love is identity affirmed.
To find a Romeo or Juliet is to find
someone who will reinforce your own
positive identity as a person in love
and extremely powerful symbolic logic.
It's power,
evidence by the sheer turmoil of
heartbreak and Shakespeare being a
writer for the common man makes it
something that is a clickable to anyone,
rich or poor.
Wherever you stand in the now chaotic
social hierarchy in essence,
and as you know it,
Shakespeare invented low down the
generations.
We can see the impact Shakespeare has
done more to define the current reality
still than any other person or group of
people since he brought the culture into
his mind at a critical historical
moment,
dissected it thought through the logic
and expressed it for all of us in
achingly beautiful verse.
Now,
you may wonder about texts like the
Odyssey or Plato's symposium or Dante
via Nova because there are accounts in
those of love,
or it may nag at you that if what I said
is true,
that love is somehow a sham.
As for those texts,
it's perhaps worth it to say that both
affection and love were around before
Shakespeare,
but the quality of love as we conceive
of it today,
the Hollywood ness of it,
the applicability to all the identity
affirming power is I think what
Shakespeare brought into the culture as
for feeling that love is a sham.
You shouldn't.
What you feel today when you're in love
is completely and totally real,
and the identity of firming power of it
is real to this is how symbolic reality
works.
It changes over time and what's real to
you and the culture at large is what's
real.
Shakespeare is not a genius because of
his intelligence.
He's a genius because of his powerful
imagination,
his symbolic imagination,
his ability to bound through steps of
emerging logics and workout new
conclusions.
What's incredible is that we all possess
the exact same ability.
That's the spectacular interplay between
culture and the mind.
The ladder can revolutionize the former.
We have only to take those symbols back
into our mind and like the great man
think them through again.
I have to thank my sociology professor
from b.
You lay a Greenfeld who introduced me to
these ideas of symbolic reality and this
crazy theory about shakespeare.
I'll put a link in the description where
you can read more from her.
She's really,
truly incredible.
Also,
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
already and follow me on Tumblr or
twitter links in the description.
I will see you next time.